this video is made possible by mandate
comity management platform creating more
efficient and intuitive ways to manage
teams and entire operations support this
show and try Monday comm through the
link in the description below
today's protagonist was one of the key
players on the giant chess board that
was Asia at the height of the Cold War
born into a political family she rose
through India's political system until
she became the first and only female
prime minister of a country
her name was Indira Gandhi in one of her
speeches she advised her followers to
maintain a bias toward action or to
encourage societal change even if it
required painstakingly small steps her
life was definitely true to that
principle as the second longest running
Indian Prime Minister mrs. Gandhi won a
war oversaw the birth of a new state
broke the traditional non-aligned stance
of India and Sivan made of her country
and nuclear superpower but it was her
internal policies that made her mandate
controversial and eventually turned her
into a target of hatred so welcome to
today's bar graphics well we will look
at the private and public life of Indira
Gandhi and how it all led to a fateful
appointments with the very people who
were meant to protect her
[Music]
Indira Gandhi was born Indira Naru on
November the 19th 1917 in Allahabad in
the state of Uttar Pradesh India
she was the firstborn child of Kamala
and Jaya Halle Nair who were no ordinary
family
Kamala came from a conservative family
of Kashmiri Brahmins the category of
priests and teachers according to the
traditional Indian caste system this
initially shy girl became an
independence activist after meeting her
future husband Jawaharlal Nehru
Nehru was a well educated lawyer and one
of the most active members of the Indian
independence movement fighting for
self-rule against the British Empire as
such she was a close associate of
Mahatma Gandhi and would later serve as
the first Prime Minister of an
independent India while Nehru and Gandhi
fight for independence through
non-cooperation is widely known Kamala's
role may have been overlooked beginning
in 1921 Kamala was actively involved in
the non-cooperation movement organizing
boycotts and picketing lines against
shops selling British goods when her
husband was jailed by the colonial
authorities Kamala shared her natural
shyness to deliver speeches to thousands
of followers on his behalf
with such fierce example set by both her
parents it is no wonder that little
Indira wanted to join the active
struggle as early as possible at age
five she carried out her first act of
rebellion she sacrificed her beloved
doll made in England by throwing it onto
a bonfire of imported British goods two
years later in 1924 the Nehru family
welcomed a second child a boy also born
in November
unfortunately the newborn died after
only two days and Indira grew up as an
only child
in 1929 she escalated her commitment to
the cause of self-determination as a
girl of only 12 Indira became a leader
within an organization numbering 60,000
young revolutionaries called vana Senna
or Monkey Brigade this name was inspired
by the traditional epic Ramayana in
which an army of monkeys helps Prince
Rama to to feed the despotic and
monstrous Ravana the van Alcinous
mission was less bellicose but still
dangerous as it involved managing the
communications and logistics that
powered mass demonstrations and protests
in March 1930 in dear
Kamala were participating in one of
these such protests outside in Christian
College and Allahabad
Indira's mother suddenly collapsed due
to heat stroke and eighteen-year-old
students at the college rushed to our
aid his name was Feroz Gandhi no
relation to Mahatma this chance
encounter would prove to be the most
important of India's life so far
Feroze became good friends of Indira and
her mother even helping to look after
Kamala when she later contracted
tuberculosis by 1936 Kamala moved to
Switzerland to treat her tuberculosis
but this was in vain she passed away on
February the 28th 1936 while her husband
was in prison shortly after her mother's
death Indira traveled to Britain to
enroll at Somerville College in Oxford
to complete her studies she never
attained a degree though as her
concentration may have been swayed by a
big distraction one that happened to be
studying at the nearby London School of
Economics Feroz Gandhi
[Music]
Indira and Feroz rekindled their
friendship which turned into a courtship
and then into an engagement like in
DARAB Pharaohs was also well educated
and involved in the independence
movement and he loved Indira despite all
this his potential father-in-law
Neru objected to the union nari simply
had a personal dislike of the young
Gandhi and as father of the bride he was
entitled to a powerful opinion as an
Aries were a family under the spotlight
many ordinary citizens also chipped in
to criticize the engagement on the basis
that he was Parsi not a Hindu like
Indira or that non arranged marriages
were not the norm in fact there was such
public outcry against the match that the
other Gandhi the Mahatma had to offer a
public statement of support which
included the request I invite the
writers of the use of letters to shed
your wrath and bless the forthcoming
marriage despite the objections and the
abuse Indira taught everybody a lesson
in determination by marrying Feroz on
March the 26th 1942 two years later
Indira gave birth to her first son Rajiv
followed in 1946 by Sanjay
unfortunately this marriage was not a
happy one Feroz began having
extramarital affairs almost immediately
things only got worse after August the
15th 1947 this is the dates in which
nari became the first Prime Minister of
an independent India to which she added
the title of foreign minister in October
of the same year
in this capacity narrow hands olds the
first of many crises over Kashmir a
border region disputed with Pakistan as
work kept piling up on Nehru's desk he
enlisted his daughter
Indira's helped to be his personal
assistants this was an unofficial role
although it became apparent to him and
to the leadership of his party the
Indian National Congress or ANC that
Indira's contribution was key to his
carrying out his functions Indira was
spending more and more time with his
father's cabinet eventually moving away
from her hometown of
Allahabad to the capital Delhi her two
sons followed with her while Feroz
decided to stay back to concentrate on
his work editing the National Herald but
this arrangement also gave him free rein
to pursue more and esteana liaisons
during this de facto separation Indira
appeared to be completely absorbed by
her
ministerial and political duties this is
probably the truth however we should
mention that a book published in 1978
presents a different image this is the
autobiography of M that high private
secretary to Prime Minister Nehru from
1946 to 1959 the 28th chapter title she
was removed from the final edition but
it was recently a reimagine to Indian
online media according to this chapter
Indira tried to seduce Matt hi in
November of 1947 and quite aggressively
so he yielded the day after but due to
being completely inexperienced Indira
had to first educate him by giving him
two books about sex and female anatomy
the chapter alleges that the clandestine
relationship continued for more than ten
years until the winter of 1958 while
visiting India on urgent official
business Matt I caught her with another
man a yoga instructor this chapter may
not have even been written by Matai and
even if it were Indira's close
associates strongly refute these rumors
according to a former leader of the
Indian National Congress NAT wah sing it
would have been materially impossible
for Indira to carry out some Dangerous
Liaisons
according to sing it was just not
possible for her to have an affair there
were security men under the bet of
course you're not made of wood but this
is the price you pay you don't have a
private life
[Music]
despite their marital issues the Gandhis
presented a united front in the arena of
indian politics during the parliamentary
elections of 1951 and 1952 Indira became
the campaign manager for Feroz Indira
clearly had a knack for campaigning and
succeeded in securing a victory for
husbands after starting to serve as an
MP for odds that moved Delhi but he did
not join his family preferring to live
in a separate house from then on both
Gandhi's made their bid to grow in
status within the ruling party the
Indian National Congress although
admittedly in two very different
fashions Feroz did so by exposing the
corruption within his father-in-law's
government he exposed a major scandal
involving bribes paid by prominent
insurance companies to the finance
minister TT krishnamacharya because of
this Feroz began to emerge as the new
rising star within India's political
circles on the other hands Indira was
following another route rising from the
inside of the iron seas party structure
in 1955 Indira first became the member
and then a president of the Working
Committee of the Indian National
Congress the inner circle that decided
the party's policies in 1958 for all
suffered a heart attack during a state
visit to Bhutan Indira rushed him back
to Delhi and took care of him for the
following year
silk she managed to advance her career
within the party and in 1959 Indira
became president of the Indian National
Congress marred by poor health 4oz could
not match her rise on September the 8th
1960 he suffered another cardiac arrest
this time it was fatal the marriage of
Indira and Feroz had not been the
happiest in addition to affairs and long
periods of separation their life was
marred by frequent vicious arguments
according to India's biographers
Sagarika Ghose
this was because both were extreme
individualist swith the urge to dominate
the other and yet Indira remembered
those confrontations with fondness I
like to think that those quarrels
enlivened our life because without them
we would have had had a normal life but
banal and boring we didn't deserve a
banal and boring life
[Music]
shortly after the death of India's
husband father's health began declining
it did not help that in July of 1962
India and China entered a war over some
border disputes which ended with a
Chinese victory in November
Nerys condition worsens leading to his
death on May the 27th 1964 nary was
succeeded as Prime Minister by allow
Bahadur Shastri who appointed Indira as
Minister of Information and Broadcasting
as a minister indira proved very adapted
building her image with well-planned
publicity stunts such as the one taking
place during the indo-pakistani war of
1965 this confrontation over the control
of the Kashmir border region took place
from the 5th of August to the 22nd of
September in 1965 when a UN resolution
finally imposed a ceasefire that summer
Indira plans a holiday retreat in
Kashmir despite repeated warnings by
security forces that Pakistani troops
had advanced very close to Hotel Indira
Gandhi refused to move the incident
fetched a huge national and
international media attention it would
take only a few months from that for
Indira to take a role in center stage on
the 11th of January 1966 Prime Minister
Shastri died immediately his fellow
party members began squabbling and
plotting to appoint a successor the
leadership of the Indian National
Congress was then split into two
currents one more conservative and the
other with more socialist leanings these
divisions made them unable to settle on
a candidate and so they started
considering an appointment for Indira
Gandhi they had been led to believe that
she would be easily manipulated she
would be the perfect compromise
candidate after much deliberation Indira
was chosen as the prime ministerial
candidate by the Congress High Command
in direct campaigned hard and emerged
victorious On January the 24th 1966 at
the age of 49 Indira Gandhi had become
the prime minister of one of the largest
and most populous countries on earth she
was not the first ever woman to be
elected head of state or head of
government in fact she was only the
third the honour of being the first
belongs to kurtik and keema chairwoman
of the Tuvans People's Republic from
1940 to 1944 the country was annexed by
the USSR and doesn't exist anymore the
first elected Prime Minister was still
existing
country was Sirimavo Bandaranaike in
1960 she became the head of government
in sri lanka back then called salon so
mrs. Gandhi may have not set a record in
terms of timing but she could wield an
amount of power that her predecessors
definitely could not boast and that
power was about to increase just before
we get into that power increase I want
to say a really quick word about Monday
calm Monday calm is a team management
tool which is perfect for teams of any
size maybe it's just you and another
freelancer working together or maybe
you've got thousands of people working
for you or maybe like me you're
somewhere in between although definitely
closer to these smaller ends if you're
not a fan of long meetings who is or get
lost in Excel sheets and whiteboard
presentations then Monday comm is
perfect for you Monday has replaced all
of these with an intuitive and
empowering platform that's very popular
even with a non tech teams I'm not a
particularly techy person myself and I
like that it's just really easy to use
for everyone
Monday comm currently works with tens of
thousands of teams and is trusted by
giants like Discovery Channel we work
over many more so empower your team and
make them feel like they're a part of
something bigger with Monday comm you
can get started with a link in the
description below and let's get back to
today's video
[Applause]
when mrs. Gandhi was elected the IMC
party was split into two opposing
factions one of the two Indira sided
with the socialist leaning won the I&C
was further weakened when new
parliamentary elections took place in
1967 and the party lost 60 seats in the
lower house in normal situations this
landslide defeat would spell the fall of
the cabinet in charge but the person in
charge of the cabinet was not your
normal Prime Minister Indira Gandhi
proved that her tenacity to cling to
power was unparalleled in order to
ensure the survival of our governments
miss Gandhi went as far as forging a
coalition with the socialist and
communist parties something unthinkable
a few years earlier during her father's
term in office so why do I say
unthinkable
well narrow may have had a moderate
interest in socialist political and
economic reform but in the context of
the Cold War
he definitely avoided siding with the
socialist bloc he also didn't side with
the capitalist bloc for that matter
either narrow alongside Egypt Nasser and
Yugoslavia stee toe was one of the key
leaders of the non-aligned countries
while the world debated capitalism
versus communism India was mostly
uninterested in taking a side now though
Nehru's daughter and success are far
from being easily swayed was taking
decisive action to steer India into a
much clearer socialist direction
domestically in 1969 mrs. Gandhi's
cabinet nationalized the fourteen
largest banks in India as well as the
four most important oil companies other
reforms included the abolition of
privileges for the Maharajah's who still
held power in several of India states
finally mrs. Gandhi initiated an
agricultural reform based on the Green
Revolution concepts developed by US
scientist Norman Borlaug combination of
mechanized agriculture and development
of new breed's of high-yield plants
thanks to Gandhi's reforms India
normally beset by periodic famines
became an exporter of surplus rice and
wheat as far as foreign policy goes
Indira Gandhi's time in office was
marked by tension and outright hostility
toward China Pakistan in the u.s. at the
same time India signed a peace
friendship and cooperation treaty with
the Soviet Union in August of 1971
marking a further drift away from
equidistant non-alignment and towards
the socialist bloc but let's proceed in
order the embassy with China
back from the 1962 war and was
exacerbated by Beijing's nuclear tests
in 1967 the shadow of this atomic threat
prompted Gandhi to stop pursuing India's
own nuclear program with Indra seven
years the country was able to perform
their first underground detonation the
rivalry with Pakistan over Kashmir was
as old as India's independence and had
resulted already into border wars the
two countries were about to enter a
further conflict in 1971 at that time
Pakistan was split into two separate
territories East and West Pakistan
separated by northern India azama burns
armed forces launched a violent
counterinsurgency campaign in the
eastern half to suppress the Awami
League and independent iStent the
results of this internal struggle was at
about ten million East Pakistani
citizens fled into India as refugees the
unprecedented humanitarian crisis
stretched India's resources to the limit
and it prompted Indira Gandhi to harshly
condemn the repression on the 31st of
March soon she started doing something
more than just speaking sternly and Dara
started supporting the Awami League in
their independence fight this was
effectively a war by proxy against
Pakistan a calculated move to weaken the
hostile neighbour and create a
friendlier government on the
northeastern border toward the ends of
the year this local conflict it had
taken on regional then international
connotations but it simply Pakistan did
not like India China did not like India
so China supported Pakistan and enter a
new player the USA China and the Soviet
Union were not best pals anymore so
Nixon sought a rapprochement with Mal
ago the u.s. like China who liked
Pakistan the u.s. plant to help Pakistan
shoot India declare war all of this
implies that if China dislikes India and
if the u.s. dislikes India India is
going to make friends with a country
those two also dislike the Soviet Union
hence the peace friendship and
cooperation treaty that I mentioned
earlier in December of 1971 the conflict
by proxy against Pakistan became a
full-fledged war on the 3rd of December
Pakistan decided to retaliate against
India's involvement with the Awami
League by bombing Indian airfields in
the western regions of Punjab and
Kashmir the Indian government under
Indira Gandhi had proven able to take
quick decisive actions and the military
no different the Indian Air Force
retaliated on the 4th and quickly
achieved air superiority on the grounds
the army launched a quick attack into
East Pakistan converging on the regional
capital dakar on the 9th of december the
war risked escalating beyond the indian
sub-continent when Nixon ordered for a
u.s. fleet to head towards the theatres
of action so what what have happens if
the US had provided direct support to
Pakistan well we'll never know by the
16th of December dagger had fallen to
the Indian Army and the separatist
forces of the Awami League the Indian
victory in the 3rd war with Pakistan was
a personal triumph for Indira Gandhi and
resulted in the birth of a new nation
East Pakistan seceded and became
Bangladesh after the peace had been
signs the Prime Minister issued a clear
warning in an interview with media to
powers both foreign and domestic I'm not
a person to be pressured by any body or
any nation
[Music]
[Laughter]
the 1970s have begun well for mrs.
Gandhi and she would soon score another
triumph in 1972 the iron seat faced the
Socialist Party in national
parliamentary elections Gandhi's party
triumphed in the ballot boxes thanks to
the recent victory over Pakistan and
because of her campaign promise to
eradicate poverty the defeated socialist
leader Raj Narain raised allegations of
corruption and electoral malpractice
soon the socialist and other opposition
parties took to the street protesting
against Gandhi's government as the
decade progressed Gandhi's economic and
social reforms were largely nullified by
rising inflation and a generally poor
state of the economy all of this only
played into the hands of the protesters
nerine's charges were formalized with
the High Court in Allahabad in June 1975
they ruled against the Prime Minister
now Indira Gandhi was constitutionally
expected to step down from office but
she had already made it clear once she
wasn't gonna be pressured by anybody as
unrest spread throughout the country
following the court ruling mrs. Gandhi
took this as the perfect occasion to
declare a state of emergency
giving her extraordinary powers to rule
by decree the period of emergency rule
lasted two years and it would be a black
moment for Indian democracy the country
became a dictatorship in orbit named as
an authoritarian ruler Indira Gandhi
ordered political opponents and other
activists to be jailed and press freedom
was limited India's main accomplice and
confidant was her second born son Sanjay
taking advantage of extraordinary powers
Sanjay put into practice some projects
of his first the forced removal of slum
dwellings more importantly India enacted
population control via forced
sterilization this draconian measure was
considered a necessary evil to allow the
country to prosper India's government
launched a campaign of vasectomies
starting with public employees they were
required to go through sterilization to
receive their salaries the campaign was
then extended to any male citizen who
would be offered cash or even just
cooking oil as an incentive to accept a
vasectomy
Sanjay's plans did not stop there
reports came out the vasectomies had
been performed even on teenage boys all
that men were being arrested and
sterilized according to an expose by
Time magazine between April 1976 and
January 1977 7.8 million Indian boys and
men were sterilized well beyond the
government target of 4.3 at the
beginnings of 1977 Indira Gandhi put an
end to the state of emergency by calling
for new elections the Prime Minister
thought that all opposition had been
effectively suppressed and this would
have been an easy win one that would
legitimize her permanence in office but
I'm gonna take a guess here and say that
1/2 of the electorate were not so keen
on Gandhi you know the one half that
doesn't like their manhood to be messed
with by forced surgery the elections
resulted in a crushing defeat the I n
see they lost almost 200 seats compared
to the previous legislature the big
winner this time was Janata Dal or
People's Party a coalition of several
smaller parties Indira accepted defeat
and stepped down mrs. Gandhi may have
left office as Prime Minister but she
still held a seat in parliament from
which she led the opposition against the
Janata Dal the new governments tried to
remove her by having a jailed briefly
twice in October of 1977 and then again
in December of 1978 on both occasions
the charges were corruption but the plan
did not work as the tenuous alliance
within the Janata started to crumble the
electorate called for stability
something that's in dearer and the iron
sea could not guarantee new elections
were called in January 1980 and mrs.
Gandhi made a surprising comeback as
head of the government during the same
elections
Indira's son Sanjay won a seat in
parliament by make mrs. Gandhi made it
clear that he was her heir apparents by
appointing him the Secretary General of
the iron sea Sanjay's rise to the top
stopped abruptly on June the 23rd 1984
years
Sanjay had been practicing with some
success in the sport of aircraft
acrobatics that day - Sanjay had gone
out flying but while performing aerial
newpsie lost control and crashed his
plane dying immediately older brother
Rajiv also had a passion for flying but
until then had not shown any interest in
politics working as a commercial pilot
for Indian Airlines but after this
tragedy Indira called him back into the
fold of family politics it was clear
that she was building at a nastic line
it was clear that Indira expected the
whole family to form a united front
behind regimes budding political career
including manaka-san Dre's Widow but
Indira and Menaka had never got on well
and in 1982 a serious
agreement broke out between the two
Maneka attended a rally held by Sanjay's
former political associates which was
perceived by the prime minister as a
slight towards Regehr Indira Auden
Menaka to leave the house in which the
extended family will live together
the daughter-in-law complied but first
she made sure that the press were aware
of her unfair eviction then she
separated Indira from hers and Sanjay's
son barren well being able to see our
grandson was a hard blow for the Prime
Minister as it turned out it became one
that she could not recover from as
public troubles piled on top of the
private ones by 1982 mrs. Gandhi had to
face the growth of secessionist
movements all over India unrest flared
up in the regions of Andhra Pradesh
Jammu and Kashmir but the most serious
threat came from the Sikhs succession
esteem Punjab northwestern India the
movement was led by John L Singh
Bhindranwale a who opposed peaceful
negotiations with the government in
Delhi in July of 1982 he established his
headquarters within the Harmandir Sahib
or Golden Temple in Amritsar Punjab the
golden temple is the most prominent
center of worship and pilgrimage for the
Sikh faith within its walls he began
recruiting supporters and amassing
weapons for an armed insurrection
India's government grew more and more
concerned about the Sikh separatist
intentions so eventually in February
1984 the Prime Minister decided to go on
the offensive the initial plan was to
have airborne commandos kidnap Indra
noiray but this was aborted in favour of
a large-scale occupation of the Golden
Temple by Special Forces operation
bluestar Blue Star launched on the night
between the 5th and 6th of June 1984 the
besieged Sikhs answered with heavy fire
including shooting RPGs and armored
vehicles but after a night of fighting
the Indian commando seized the Aqil to
hat building in which Bhindranwale a had
staged his last stand the palace was hit
by light arms fire tank shells tear gas
canisters by 6 a.m. on the 6th
resistance at sea stand Bhindranwale a's
body was discovered among the rubble 83
troops lost their lives in the assault
vs. 492 civilian fatalities some of
these fatalities were Sikh separatists
but most of them were civilians the
majority of the dead were pilgrims who
happened to be inside the temple at the
wrong time
operation bluestar was followed by
operation Woodrow's a larger military
deployments which included infantry
armor
and helicopters confronting seek
independent disks all across Punjab both
operations widened the rift between the
Sikh minority and the rest of the
country Indira Gandhi's prestige and
popularity which had made a recovery
since the 1980 re-election were heavily
tarnished once again but something much
much worse than a dip in popularity was
only horizon for the prime minister on
the morning of October the 31st 1984
Indira Gandhi was walking from her
official residence towards her office to
meet British actor Peter Ustinov he was
there to interview her for a BBC
documentary she was walking a few paces
ahead of her attendants as she
approached the gates leading out of her
gardens and 909 a.m. mrs. Gandhi folded
her hands to greet the two bodyguards
stationed at the gates these were men to
sing and sat.1 sing these guards were
not related the Sanskrit word sing means
lion and it is an essential component of
all male names among the Sikhs it was
only four months since operation
bluestar and wood rose but the Prime
Minister had no reason to mistrust her
loyal Sikh bodyguards in the case of
bent and Satwant she had made a mistake
the two had been planning their revenge
for the massacre at the golden temple
means fired the first shots with his
revolver followed by Sat ones who fired
his Sten submachine gun on full auto
Indira Gandhi was shot 30 times she was
rushed to a hospital that her death was
announced at 1:00 p.m. that same day the
following day ordinary citizens in many
cases aided and supported by police and
local authorities started a series of
violent anti secrets these resulted in
the death of more than 3,000 Sikhs the
death of the leader had sparked a period
of unrest for a country but that's
another story
[Music]
Indira Gandhi had built a political
career on the principle of bold action
independence from external pressure this
had led to successes like the Green
Revolution the victory against Pakistan
the alliance with the USSR and a stable
nuclear program India also succeeded in
ensuring the continuation of the Nehru
Gandhi dynasty shortly after the
assassination her son Rajiv was sworn in
as the new Prime Minister Rajiv remained
in power for seven years until he too
was assassinated in May of 1991 by a
suicide bomber from a Sri Lankan
military group known as the Tamil Tigers
in 1997 Rajiv's wife Sonia was elected
by I&C members as their party presidents
a key role in setting the policies of
the country Sonia Gandhi could have
easily won over the seat of Prime
Minister but the fact that she is
Italian by birth did not allow her to
cover official government functions let
alone become the head of said government
in 2017 Sonia continued the dynastic
tradition and handed her the direction
of the party to her son Rahul however
this was the story of a strong leader
and as usual there are shadows behind
the trance it is simply not possible to
overlook the excesses of the emergency
years the allegations of corruption the
poor management's of the economy and
finally the immediate and lasting
effects of operation bluestar so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe also why not check
out our sister channel Geographics if
this channels about people that channel
is about places it is linked to below
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]